l'ordre du jour appelle la question
orale numéro 573 de monsieur michel
bécot à madame la ministre des affaires
sociales et de la santé vous avez la
parole me reconnaît merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre ma
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
de la santé
l'ensemble des acteurs du nord deux
sèvres en charge du projet de
restructuration du centre hospitalier
nord de sève satin belz et juillet
derniers à ce qu'enfin l'état donne son
feu vert à cette opération initiée en
1996 suite à la fusion des trois
hôpitaux de bressuire et parthenay et
war
il en a pas été ainsi puisque la
décision a une nouvelle fois été
repoussée en complément d'information et
de nouvelles expertises ont été
demandées
l'inquiétude dans le nord de sève et
grande madame la milice et cette non
décision est difficilement
compréhensible par nos concitoyens
madame la ministre je vous remercie de
bien vouloir me préciser si oui ou non
les habitants du nord de sève peuvent
continuer à espérer et enfin voir ce
projet aboutir fin décembre 2013 je vous
remercie madame bonamie liste des
éléments qu'il vous sera possible de me
communiquer merci chers collègues la
parole et à madame la ministre
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
sénateur michel bécot là aussi je vous
réponds en lieu et place de marisol
touraine comme vous le savez monsieur le
sénateur dès sa prise de fonction
justement la ministre des affaires
sociales et de la santé a pris
connaissance de l'état d'avancement du
projet de restructuration du centre
auspices et hospitalier nord deux sèvres
dont elle sait qu'il est
particulièrement attendu non seulement
de vous mais de la population et qui est
très soutenu par les collectivités
territoriales de la région poitou
charentes vous l'avez d'ailleurs déjà
interrogé sur ce sujet en octobre 2012
la ministre a souhaité que le projet de
restructuration soit instruit assez
rapidement sur l'égide du comité de la
performance et de la modernisation de
l'offre de soins là copé remet au
puisqu'on aime bien les abréviations
qu'elle a installé en décembre 2012 le
cope remet au pardon a déclaré le projet
éligible en avril 2013 il a formulé
plusieurs recommandations techniques en
vue d'un examen pour une décision
complètement définitive et finale pour
répondre à ces attentes l'établissement
et l' agence régionale de santé
travaillent actuellement à la
finalisation de ce dossier afin de
garantir que le projet médical qui
sous-tend cet investissement soit
conforme au référentiel les plus
exigeants qu'ils soient il est notamment
attendu de l'établissement qui
s'engagent résolument sur le
développement des prises en charge
ambulatoire et qu'ils organisent le
parcours des patients en lien avec
l'ensemble des acteurs de soins sur la
totalité du territoire donc la ministre
des affaires sociales et de la santé et
confiante sur la capacité de
l'établissement et de l' agence
régionale de santé pour répondre à ses
attentes en vue je pense d'un examen
final pas par le cop ermo qu'elle
souhaite relativement proche que je ne
peux pas vous fixé aujourd'hui mais le
calendrier me semble assez resserrée
si madame la ministre
chers collègues ou bien vous voulez
réagir
non madame la ministre
simplement un mot pour vous dire que
nous comptons sur vous et sur votre
gouvernement pour enfin faire sortir ce
projet qui depuis maintenant 1996 est
dans les cartons merci merci chers
collègues